من قاعده الاعداد الجويه في الدوحه انطلقت
الرحله الاولى التابعه للقوات الجويه
الاميريه القطريه لنقل المساعدات القطريه
الى مطار بورت سودان وعلامتها مواد غذائيه
هذا
الدور في تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه للشعب
السوداني ليس غريب على قطر نحن تعودنا في
كل الازمات السابقه التي مر بها السودان
خصوصا في اقليم دارفورد كانت قطر في
المقدمه سباقه دائما
بتقديم يد العون والمساعده كل محتاج اليها
الشعب السوداني
المؤسسات الخيريه القطريه ممثله بقطر
الخيريه والهلال الاحمر القطري وصندوق قطر
للتنميه بادرت الى الاستجابه العاجله
لتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه في المناطق
المتضرره من النزاع المسلح الذي تشهده
مناطق متفرقه في السودان في انطلاق اول
رحله اغافيه انسانيه جمهوريه السودان
تقديم المساعدات القطريه بالتعاون
والتنسيق مع صندوق قطر التنميه واللي
نستهدف فيها اخواننا اللي نجحوا من
المناطق الصراع في الخرطوم والمناطق
الاخرى باذن الله راح يتم تسليمها في
بورتسودان وبالتنسيق مع الجهات الحكوميه
راح يتم نقل وتوزيع هذه المساعدات للاخوه
المتضررين والنازحين في المناطق اللي هي
الامنه 60 طنا من المواد الغذائيه هي كميه
هذه المساعدات المتجهه الى ميناء بورسودان
على البحر الاحمر هناك سيتم انزالها
واجلاء مواطنين سودانيين وفق خطه
المساعدات الانسانيه القطريه العاجله
تقوم المؤسسات الخيريه القطريه بالتنسيق
مع عدد من المؤسسات والمنظمات الدوليه
بوضع ترتيبات لتوفير المساعدات الانسانيه
العاجله في عدد من المناطق المتضرره لقطر
الخيريه حضور في الميدان لتقديم الامدادات
الغذائيه الطبيه فيما يقوم الهلال الاحمر
القطري بوضع الترتيبات اللازمه لتقديم
المساعدات الانسانيه العاجله الطائره
القطريه اجلت كذلك عددا من السودانيين
المقيمين في قطر والذين تجاوز عددهم 184
شخصا من فئات عمريه مختلفه
في ايام الهدن الوضع بيستقر شويه فالواحد
بيقدر يطلع فاخذنا القرار كان قرار صعب
وانه الواحد يطلع من البيت في ظل الحرب
وفي ظل الضرب واصوات الرصاص لمن وصلنا
مدينه بورسودان
سمعنا بمبادره السيد السفير والحمد لله
الان يتم عمليه الاجابه بنجاح ومن المقرر
ان تسير القوات الجويه الاميريه القطريه
رحلات اخرى لنقل المساعدات ومنها مستشفى
الميداني ومواد طبيه وادويه احمد الجاسم
الجزيره من قاعده الاعداد الجويه الدوحه